okay so I was asked by Dennis Allison to
talk about what makes games addictive
and and I and you notice my title was
different it was principles of
engagement and I haven't used the word
addiction in the title and I'm not going
to say a lot about it I think this is a
really interestingly controversial topic
as some of you may know in the 50s there
was the comic books care where comic
books were going to destroy our youth
and there was a huge uproar about it in
both political and moral and religious
and I kind of feel like there may be
something like that going on today comic
books were selling 80 to 100 million
units a week of popular series and and
they went coup they crashed as a result
of this outrage I think they have kind
of recovered to a certain extent in the
graphic novels of today but but we've
moved on of course there are questions
about addiction and violence with games
for sure and I think those are
legitimate questions and there's a
there's research on the topic if you
don't I do know people who have lost a
year of their life to world of warcraft
and I have friends who have lost a year
of their life to world of warcraft
so those things certainly happen and I'm
not saying that they're don't I'm not an
apologist either for games
there certainly are anecdotal accounts
of kids and others who have been
seriously harmed in some way although
causality is really the question here I
know of a kid who had a similar problem
with 8 millimeter film making he spent
all of his youth making 8 millimeter
films and didn't rat luck
lousy in school and when he finally
applied to go to film school he didn't
get in because his grades were too bad
he did okay his name's Steven Spielberg
and he's done okay
I have friends who are surfer dudes and
they devote their life to surfing and
surfing is a very similar phenomena to
what we're talking about here
meaning it's an incredibly engaging
experience that people who some people
get completely and wrapped in it and
that becomes their lives so what I want
to not do is get into that part of it I
could talk about that that would be it
that would be a science talk on the
current research but since his current
research is inconclusive
I don't think that would be an
interesting use of time and besides what
Dennis actually asked me to talk about
was what we do to make games addictive
so I'm going to I'm going to pivot on
the word addictive and turn it to
irresistible engaging and yeah and I
left addiction in for exactly that
reason I as you may know National
Geographic had a video series on animals
that was having a really hard time
getting off the ground because they they
kind of the advertising and marketing
was all very kind of science oriented
and nature oriented so then they took a
took a cue from there from market here
and they turned it into life and deaths
and sex and all this other stuff and
their sales went through the roof yeah
exactly so so I kept addiction in the
title because I figured it would gather
attention but that's not what I'm gonna
talk about but I am going to try if I
can I'm going to try to talk about some
things that we actually do not just
principles but things that we actually
do in designing games
so there's lots of places for you to and
part of the reason for that is there's
lots of places for you to find material
on on design of games and principles of
design of games my observation right now
is that none of the well with one
exception none of the great game
designers have written a book like one
exception is Chris Crawford who was a
great game designer he was the guy who
did Atari games in his heyday he was the
leader of that and he did write a book
but by and large the people if you if
you find a book on the topic that's
somebody who's not a great game designer
and if you find a great game it's
designed by somebody hadn't written a
book so and I haven't written a book and
I don't plan to and I don't actually
necessarily consider myself a great game
designer world I've had considerable
success in the area but I was working
with a lot of really great game
designers when I did it and a lot of
great other people which I'll talk about
so what I didn't want to do is rehash
just rehash the material of these books
I'm going to talk a little I kiss I am
going to talk a little bit about it in
order to create a frame and then I want
to talk about what and use that as kind
of the jumping-off point to talk about
things that we actually do I by the way
art of computer game design which I
think in the upper left hand corner is
actually a very good book on the topic
it was written in 1980 blah blah blah
blah
I have a first 87 I think actually I
have a first edition copy and it's well
summed I remember in 1985 I know the
year for a particular reason
I have a big Thanksgiving party at my
house and so I was inviting a lot of
people over the next day because this
was the day before and I decided to set
up a Mac one of the old Macs and I was
going to put a new game on it that I'd
been told was really good called balance
of power and I was sending it up for the
kid because I figure you know the kids
are going to be really bored with the
adults hanging out
at the barbecue so they would want to do
something fun so they'd play this game
so I set it up I never played it I open
the box I got put it in the computer and
booted the thing up and thought well I
should at least see if it works yeah he
knows the punchline the next thing I
know it's dawn literally I came I the
Sun was shining in my eyes that's what
happened was when the Sun came up it
happened to shine through the window and
into my eyes and that made me what time
is it G and it was dawn well I could
just finish this level and so I played
for another two hours so so I would I
would propose to you that Chris Crawford
the designer of that game is in fact a
great game designer historically and and
that he knows something about it he has
written a book so if you want to read
that book I highly recommend it actually
I recommend other books it's not that
they're bad books in general the issue I
think is that there is a if you're not a
cook and you can describe what cooks do
that's great but that doesn't mean you
can actually do it and there's an awful
lot to game making a great game that
isn't anything that I can easily talk
about but I'm going to try I'm going to
try
oh and here's some more evidence to that
prior to the onset of mobile gaming I
don't know how it served these numbers
there were about 8,000 console games
released a year of those 80 broke even
of those 10 made a substantial profit so
almost everybody who designs games
designs games that lose money and even
good designers design games that lose
money for sure there's a lot of reasons
for a game to make it or not making
we're going to talk about some of those
of course but but but the implication
there is that is that there actually
aren't that many great game designers
it's not a huge number and all
so maybe the game design you can't pick
up a book and learn how to do it
otherwise the people doing those other
8,000 games probably would have picked
up a book and read it and figured out
how to do it and then made some money
except that's not exactly how it works
so why I'm up here I was interested in
human-computer interface design from a
very long time ago I went to the very I
would school here when this was called
cognitive engineering and most of the
classes were in the mechanical
engineering department because it hadn't
yet gotten to be a discipline in its own
right and it was by analogy to the
design of a chair right the ergonomics
of chair tonight oh well we have to do
cognitive ergonomics - what would make
something easier to use or more fitting
for a human I went to gatorsburg which
was the very first conference it wasn't
yet a chi conference because Chi didn't
exist yet but it was the very first of
the human-computer interface conferences
and ACMs Chi conference was born out of
that meeting they expected to get a few
hundred people there were 800 people
there they couldn't get us all to the
lunch line before the before the next
session started it was at the National
Bureau standard wasn't to say yeah well
this is just the design community in
general and from there I went into a
consumer design and then and business
later business kind of following the
wave of that moving out of people
wanting to do good UX design started
with consumer and consumer products got
better than business products got better
and so on so I did all sorts of things
like that and this is the inflection
point that Andy was talking about I
noticed that my friend and I played a
lot of games and and you know there's
there's a there's something about that
it's like I'm paying somebody to
frustrate me and and I'm paying them for
this and it has no point I mean it's one
thing to pay for an office automation
suite which ok it's irritating that I
have to pay for it but I have to use it
and it has high value so I do that so
there's something about engagement
versus value going on here like like a
violin you know the violin must be very
valuable because it takes like 13 years
to learn right so you're going to spend
a huge chunk of your life you're going
to how to do this thing so you must it
must be worth a lot
whereas games well they're not actually
worth anything
I mean other than the time you spend and
in the enjoyment maybe you get but
there's a very high engagement that's
the enjoyment part so something about
games is almost the reverse of
everything I was designing and and I
thought I would like to know more about
this so so I got lucky I started I
talked my way into a job as a design
lead at a startup called any River
entertainment that's the upper left up
there which I suspect none of you have
played and that's out of four games that
we worked on that's the only one that
got out well that's not quite true but
anyway long story
Stewart Bond was one of the founders and
he's one of the founders of EA and he's
an incredibly smart and successful
producer non designer producer and we
had a bunch of really good designers
working for us and one by one they sort
of dropped like it's a battlefield or
something and I ended up in a field
promotion to being a designer from being
a lead designer his idea when he hired
me wasn't that I was going to design
games I had no I had only one discipline
anyway long story but I did wasn't a
proven designer and he wanted to hire
proven designers but I knew what design
process was and he wanted to instill
more modern design process into game
design business and so he hired me for
that and over the course of two years as
people were dropping like flies he
finally ended up having me do some
design work and and he liked the work
that I did and and then when any River
entertainment didn't make it as many
startups don't I ended up going to
to Electronic Arts in the UK in England
it was called the turkey studio at the
time which has been in a James Bond
movie now there was a beautiful building
the beautiful there's a John would
like it John likes to analyze buildings
in terms of things this was an
incredibly beautiful building which
absolutely didn't work anyway so I was
hired at that studio to come in and so
what had happened as ei had just bought
bullfrog bullfrog you're probably some
of you're old enough to remember
bullfrog if you were game players in
bullfrog was a very very famous game
company that did really big games in
Europe and in Japan but not so big here
and they wanted so they figured they'd
hire an American and and the American
would help them figure out what to do to
make the game more saleable in in in the
US and I did my first job there was to
do a big study of the difference between
European gaming successful European
games and successful u.s. games and it
turned out there were two things humour
the Brits are things lots of things are
funny that Americans do not like fart
and bathroom jokes for example are fine
and polite British society but not so
fine in here and and then the difficulty
level of the games the Europeans played
way more difficult games than we did
so our games were simpler so one of the
things that we called it then and this
name is still out there but although I
don't think it's quite right but we call
it mass-market gaming as opposed to
gamer gaming so the idea was we were
going to widely expand the audience but
of course as soon as you get all these
other people playing games that's not
there gamers now so it's kind of a dumb
name
the observation that we made at the time
was that the average that gaming was
like a wave that is people who started
playing games
children kept playing it for the rest of
their lives not as much but they kept
playing games to some degree and so the
audience got bigger every year by the
size of a cohort so that was kind of a
time a very optimistic view of what the
gaming market was doing that is if you
could hang in there and make games that
people would play your market would get
bigger and bigger every year so I play
tested every game that went through UK
studio it was a big studio bullfrog was
one piece of it and they had a sports
gaming piece and another another Sports
Management
nobody should play sports management is
not something Americans will ever play
it's playing a game with a spreadsheet
literally you're managing sports teams
in a spreadsheet and then they tell you
what happened at the end of the season
and you do and you take your money and
you do it again it's like it's like it's
like a resource game without any of the
fun parts it's really crazy but anyway
the Europeans like that I didn't I did
hmm the Brits like that yes the Brits
like it but so do the Germans those
games do pretty well in Germany not so
well in France
oh they do pretty well in Italy because
most of our soccer games all right hey
there's football too but that's only for
America and they don't do well all right
so what happened was I ended up being a
designer lead designer on poor games
that I wasn't always in a lead design
role because they didn't really have
that kind of a role but I was the
designer and I worked with a bunch of
other designers on populist the
beginning was the first one which when I
came in was in trouble it was a game
that had they had built and then they
tested it it didn't do well so they
didn't release it populist the beginning
sim theme park Jun Jin keeper - and then
Harry Potter which was the big game of
the studio and I did the first Harry
Potter before I delete and the issue
with onion keeper - which did got
number fourteen on the charts in the US
but it didn't have any advertising at
all because its theme was it's good to
be bad and it came out right after
Columbine so it couldn't be so they
killed a marketing campaign for it they
released it killed a marketing campaign
and it still got the number fourteen so
that was probably pretty damn good game
and I also worked with a lot of really
cool game designers including Peter who
I will quote in here Peter Molyneux who
was the founder of bullfrog and then
went on to several other gaming
companies now so I taught a couple of
classes here when was that
93 to 2003 I guess on game design and
film craft in user interface design so
it was intended for user interface
designers not game designers but
extracting principles from all this that
would be useful to people doing serious
games okay so some definitions I think
of a game of the kind that I'm taught
mostly going to talk about here as a
game a fictional reality with physics
goals obstacles means to overcome
obstacles success conditions things like
that in other words a fictional world
game mechanics or how you play the game
how do you interact with the physics of
the world what you can do how things
work how you can use things to
accomplish things what information gets
provided to you what your feedback looks
like all those kinds of things how you
know your successes and how you know
your progress that's all game mechanics
gameplay is the purpose the goals the
obstacles and how and just the necessary
strategy and tactics that you need to
work out in a classic multi level game
of the sorts that I just mentioned a
moment ago that I was involved with the
game designer is responsible for the
overall arc and the mechanics level
designers of which there are
Harry Potter we had 20 I think we had
about 15 on Dungeon Keeper too designed
the individual experiences that fit into
the overall I mean everybody works as a
team but one person might design design
five or six or seven levels in the
course of a year all right so that's
kind of what we're talking about and
from this is this is what I call the
10,000 foot view when you're starting a
game project yeah you might not have a
parachute well if you're a TA you do EA
can afford to have a game or to fail one
you need an exciting goal to constantly
consequential choices that you make to
accomplish that goal you need obstacles
to overcome
you need fun abilities to do things the
things you do need to be fun and this is
all built into tight action loops of
doing something seeing result doing
something else seeing a result etc you
need to be able to see the outcomes of
your actions clearly so you need to know
where you are there's Peter with some of
the games he designed and he's one of
the great game designers he invented the
god game populace was the first god game
which is where you're looking down on
the world and you can manipulate things
you're sort of God and he did populous
the first populous done the first
dungeon keeper syndicate black and white
and theme park now reason I bring him up
at this moment is that one of the things
about Peter that makes him so phenomenal
as a game designer is that his ideas are
terrific
look at these game propositions your god
you can throw lightning bolts cast
spells that you can cause mountains to
flatten and volcanoes to rise out of the
earth
you can release plagues of locusts
that's pretty cool
that's populous this game actually was
invented because of a programming error
one of the artists programmers was
trying to build a landscape and and it
kept shifting on him and he figured out
that he could make the landscape shift
and then he showed it to Peter and Peter
said oh that's really cool we can make a
game out of that and that's how populous
got started so recognition of weird
events that lead to great ideas that's
part of what a great game designer has
you are a bad guy a dungeon keeper
you live deep under the earth you have
damsels who are obviously in distress
because they're in the dungeon
underneath the earth and there are
heroes who are going to go down in the
tunnels and try to find and fight you
and you kill them off because you are
that you you're playing the dungeon
keeper you're playing the bad guy so
that's a pretty cool premise and kids
really like that premise Dungeon Keeper
did really well and like I said that
Dungeon Keeper 2 did really well in even
without advertising in the US so it's a
fun game you have a creature that you
get the guide and help develop and he
either goes in the direction of good or
direction of evil you choose and the
whole world slowly changes to match what
what you're doing if you if you guide
the creature into you know stomping out
villages and killing people and all that
kind of stuff the whole world darkens
and gets all and if you do the other way
then it goes the other way one of the
cool ideas he had which they didn't do
this is called black and white and it
was less than his best game because the
difficulties of the AI were enormous but
it was nonetheless a game that did quite
well and he originally had wanted to
sell it in white boxes and black boxes
and the white box would call us cost a
dollar more and the dollar would go to
garetty so you got to choose when you
were buying the game which way you
wanted to go they didn't actually do
that because of logistics of box
creation but anyway you're running a
hospital where people can dissolve in
the green slime if they get a disease
and don't get treated in time and there
are lots of fart jokes in the bathrooms
and various messes that can happen there
as you might imagine and I'm not going
to talk about it got a pand in the US
for gross humor bad leap and actually it
obviously offended the critics here it
did very well in Europe that was one of
the things I observed in looking through
the new humor in games now all of these
games have been copied in one way or
another and have forms on Rah's but
they're but he often did the one that
was the original and not original in the
sense of out of nowhere every game has a
history but but nonetheless I think
these these are they're particularly
special games so what I just told you
was getting a good game concept is
really important and then the next thing
is what is admission is therefore
foundational what are you doing are you
saving uric you saving universe you
saving a galaxy you're saving the damsel
you you're building an empire what are
you doing
so that is core to making an
irresistible game if people don't aren't
attracted to the concept then the whole
thing will not work so and in fact
populace the beginning which was a
platinum game what didn't really meet EA
standards for platinum games meaning it
sold only a million copies at the time
that was most game companies would have
died to sell a million copies of the
game but but I ended up getting to do
study of why it didn't do well and
partner it turned out to be the overall
concept is that it was kind of natives
of some kind who knows what kind and you
were helping him or you were guiding
them to fight off enemies and do the
plagues and all that kind of stuff
but the concept didn't grab people just
a high concept there didn't grab people
so that's a good place to start a hint
is usually unique in some way and this
are these are pictures from Resident
Evil which invented the genre of
survival horror and it had it had a
gimmick which was a cinematic camera I
was the way many game companies work is
usually you work a workday like most
places you work until five or six or
seven at night and then you play games
and so you don't you can't play games
during work time except for the game
you're working on but you get but you
can play games afterward so when this
came out at 6:30 at night I went into
the into the conference room and started
playing Resident Evil which I knew
nothing about other than it got good
reviews and I played it for way too long
four or five hours probably and like
this is actually a shot from the very
first scene you walk through a door you
see a body on the ground and it's got
blood around this you think it's dead
and then suddenly it starts getting up
so it's a zombie game before this this
particular zombie craze it's a zombie
game and it was scary because you notice
that the close up the camera cut to
close up normally in games before that
the little bodies head would kind of
move and you kind of see the 16 pixel
image of your enemy but no it cut the
close up this game does all sorts of
standard horror cinematic tricks you
walk down a hallway and some rabid dogs
crash
the windows on both sides between you
and the camera that's a very threatening
move and in a cinematic shot from a
movie so this game had a cinematic
camera as as you move to the game that
it could you would trigger cutaways to
horror shots and so here I am 10:30 11
o'clock at night nobody's left in the
office I've just had a four or five-hour
horror show and I noticed that my car I
can see out the window and my cars on
the other side of the parking lot and
there's nothing else in the parking lot
and there's like one or two lights and
that's about it and I'm thinking I
really don't want to walk across that
parking lot into my car that feels
really scary right now a very effective
game with a good high concept they
didn't have it in the game but they sure
had in it they forgot me okay so a game
also in addition to a high concept needs
to satisfy some basic human need and you
know if you think about it beating
winning things achievement exploring
socializing building stuff thinking
solving puzzles and combinations of all
these things either basic human needs
and games need to need to deal with
these kinds of things when I look at any
particular game this is one of the
things I think about what needs to
dissolve and many of you may be familiar
with Maslow's hierarchy of human needs
this is actually late in life he added
three - the one you normally see and
this is the full one and the reason the
pool one is interesting is because the
more of these you look at the more you
can think about what my game does for
each of these things this is work in the
forties and there's more recent work on
on hierarchy of needs and values than
Maslow for sure this isn't a talk on
that subject so I won't go into all of
that but a game to start
the trancing original idea is going to
solve some set of it's going to let you
deal with some set of these things and
most games are generous a word that has
entered the UX vocabulary in the last
few years
generous in the sense that they solve
more than one you do you know somebody
asks you for a and you give them a and B
and C because you're generous and
generous design means you expand upon
the things that are there and in fact
most games do that and have been doing
that since way back because if you only
had one thing you do then very likely
you're going to be a puzzle game or you
know you're going to be a simple game
and that's fine
nothing wrong with that but and those
kinds of games are very popular but most
of the video console games are richer
than that more things are going on at
one time
so in a real-time strategy game you'll
be exploring the map you'd be combatting
you'll be gathering resources building
stuff you'd be doing building protecting
things advancing solving problems along
the way and puzzles a rich section of
this in that game a rich section of this
this also allows the player to pick to a
certain extent what they want to play at
this is an important thing you need
players at any given moment may be more
interested in combat or more interested
in building up their forces gauge a game
like Age of Empires one of the early
successful resource games you could I
haven't seen people who spend almost
their entire time building a beautiful
laid out village it's like a
construction game but it's also a combat
game it's a resource gathering game it's
got lots of things going on there so you
can do more than one because there are
lots of kinds of people and people have
lots of needs there are lots of kinds of
games these are just an example I have a
list here which I will not read of about
30 or 40 different game types and the
point here
is also when you're building a game you
will not be irresistible to everybody
you'll be irresistible to the people who
like your kind of game there are kinds
of games I do not play I do not play
doomed
first-person shooters quake all those
kinds of games because I get sick and I
don't like being sick so I don't play
those kind of games I play lots of other
kind of games but you know people's
choice in games is very specific and you
play the kind of games you like so for
example oh here's another one I don't
play this is a wings tiny wings tiny
wings it's a great game it's essentially
a single button game when you wanted to
work at bullfrog as a programmer you had
to build a single button game that was
part of the interview with build a
single button game meaning the only
control is down or up on a button now
this is a great game the X's into it
because it's not a great game so is a
doom of course or that might be quite I
don't remember but they're great games
but they're not my game I don't actually
like that kind of time pressure
candy crush i I just hate it when I get
chocolates in the in the game board I
don't like it it forces timing I read
this all I like solving problems but I
don't like to be forced in time in time
when I'm doing it on the other hand so
Angry Birds great that's fine mist of
course the earliest one I can think of
that I really like that way and in the
middle of what is a stealth game stealth
games generally don't I think that's one
of the Metal Gear Solid games stealth
games generally the timing is to slow
down to wait for the guard to pass to
wait for the right opportunity to make
your move
I find that both tense and satisfying I
don't like being pressed but I don't
mind waiting for exactly the right
moment to do do
I need to do so I do like stealth games
everybody is like that everybody has
their tastes the things that appeal to
them and the things that do not well
here's my example of the violin but the
point I wanted to make here is you know
I probably will never in my life run a
two hour marathon I'm not built for it I
couldn't have done it when I was 20 I'm
not going to do it now I am NOT going to
ever be a terrific tennis player I play
tennis sometimes but you know I have a
limit on how much time energy I'm going
to put into it so do you think that in
the course of a 5150 our game I'm going
to learn how to be a commander for an
intergalactic force of thousands of
spaceships that are combatting thousands
of enemies probably not so there's a
trick in games games do require skill
and you have to develop certain skills
to do things but the primary thing that
is your skill is seniority in game that
is we do lots of things to give you more
power more capability more scope with
time in game yes you have to learn how
to do basic set of skills but actually
you haven't become a masterful
sharpshooter you become a slightly
better sharpshooter and you've put
enough time in the game that we give you
more power a better gun or maybe it or
maybe we just completely cheat and the
size of the area that you're that your
ammo hits changes that your bullets hit
changes there's lots of ways to cheat
this now some of it is quite explicit
like I just said and some of it is more
implicit certain kinds of games are more
easily done but like here this is
actually the inventory for
populace the beginning and those are all
spells and as you go through the game
you get more and more powerful spells so
you can play against more and more
powerful enemies that's really cool but
you didn't get there by being more
skillful at it you got there by playing
the game for longer and being about
equally skillful you don't notice that
and when you get into a game generally
you'll see player into a multi-user game
like a massively multiplayer game you'll
see players at all different levels and
there are skill differences for sure and
there are absolutely real tournaments
where people fight each other and and
and you know the more skillful one wins
but if we had to depend on that we could
never be mass market mass market
requires that everyone of you think
you're great if you stay in my game long
enough you're going to think you're
great and I'm going to give you rewards
all along the way so you keep thinking
you're getting better and better and
better what you're actually getting is
older and possibly worse but in the
course of the game there will be minor
skill and enhancements that you need to
make but your skill level may be going
this but your apparent skill level in
the game is going like this your range
and that we do that because we want to
keep everyone in the game and if we
didn't do that only the best people only
the best players would stay in the game
and by the way that's a tiny audience
those two-hour marathoners well we
haven't gotten our first one yet but
we're going to have them soon and it's
going to be a very small core to people
right even the three-hour marathon is a
small court of people compared to what
we want to get as people in our games so
this is one of the big teeth that we do
and it's built into the games and
there's we also have cheat systems and
things like that
to help you even out things or to
accomplish something instead of getting
so frustrated you quit but that also
creates interesting social dynamics I
was at a party a really boring adult
party and I heard some fun sounds coming
from the back and I walked back there
and there were a bunch of 12 year olds
playing a game so I decided
to join them because it was way more fun
and one of them became a friend and we
ended up playing Age of Empires together
this is quite a while ago he's now a
graduate of Harvard Law and and
practicing in China so it was quite a
long time ago but but but the thing that
was cool was he of course he's a 12 year
old he knows every cheat there is out
there he's done all the work I of course
I'm an adult I don't have my time for
that and so I'm not doing very well in
the game so every and we were playing
together against the computer because he
liked playing with me and what would
happen is every so often he would give
me something he would do a cheat and
give me something that I needed to do a
little better and he'd tell me he was
giving it to me because it comes to the
game system and so it was a weight great
way for him to have a relationship with
an adult in which he actually was the
one who knew the most and could do the
best job in the game and and you know
that that kind of social dynamics is
okay that's an extreme example or a
rather a very specific example but that
happens between people and games
normally all the time it's a way that
people can layer out in games and become
better and better and play together and
do things like that without having to
worry about being really the best at
anything because you won't get very far
if you have to be the best so so games
so now we've gotten up to the point we
were actually designing the game we got
the concept we got the mission we got
all that kind of stuff it's in the right
category for us now we're talking about
engagement and this is and games are a
flow phenomena so flow is a mental state
of immersion and an activity we then get
energized focus full involvement and
enjoyment in the process and we see
examples here surfing a tennis gaming
well I wouldn't do that but if you want
to I'm sure it's slow it's also insane
so
flow state intense and focus
concentration on the present merging of
action and awareness loss of reflective
self-consciousness being so engrossed
that other needs become negligible and
alteration of the subjective experience
of time now I just told you a story
about that a few minutes ago didn't I
balance of power I was gone for 12 hours
just gone no sleep no food nothing to
drink just gone and then another two
hours after I woke up I went back so
here what I'm trying to do is and this
is small but what I was trying to do was
reflect on what are the conditions for
flow and think about how they apply how
how we interpret them in gaming in the
building game context clear set of goals
that's the mission you got to have lots
of missions missions are hierarchical
your big mission you know to defeat the
universe evil in the universe but now I
got a free this world and to do that I
got to do this and this and this and do
that I got to do this
so missions compelling purpose Oh saving
the universe that's pretty compelling
purpose a lot of games have very fantasy
oriented purposes not all of them but a
lot of them do personal agency
consequential actions in the game what I
do must matter now you think that well
of course but a lot of narrative games
in order to try to save on resource
you'll take this path and it will
converge with this path people figure
that out and then they don't like the
game anymore and they stop that's why a
lot of narrative games did not work
we're more sophisticated about narrative
games now than we were then but anyway
clear immediate feedback I need to know
what the state is what my progress is
and what the actions I just did
accomplished I need to be able to tell
that close match between perceived
challenge and perceived skills fairness
is really important in games if I sense
that it's unfair meaning that I can't
learn my way through this obstacle then
that and that's so like the seniority
thing
has to be pretty subtle you can't let
people know what you're doing that's
really important and then survivable
frustration I'm going to talk about
frustration curves in a minute but
frustration is what I manage when I'm
designing a game frustration is my
primary management tool for you for
getting you by whatever and getting you
to continue all the way to the game
putting you on a leash so the
requirements you've got to know what to
do or believe that you can figure it out
you've got to know how to do it or
believe that you can acquire the skill
you got to know how well you're doing
am i and part of that is so I can figure
out what I need to get better at and get
better at it I need to know where to go
exploration is fun but not if I am lost
those are different experiences they
look the same from the outside you're
wandering around but in one case I'm
going to quit playing and in the other
case I'm not and games have all sorts of
tools in them for helping people who
feel lost without giving away things
that without getting rid of exploration
high perceived challenge you need a
challenge ramp to create that always
keeps your challenge level high but high
perceived skills which are either at or
just below the task you're being asked
to do so that you perceive of yourself
as being well I lost this time but I can
I'll get it next time
and the course freedom from distraction
which in games it's true in the world at
large as well of course but inside the
game there has to not be things that
distract me from what I'm trying to
accomplish unless that's part of the
game so there's the rule from the master
simple hot and deep so we're going to
design a game we want to design a game
that's simple it's hot and it's deep not
all games need to be simple hot and deep
there are all sorts of wild exceptions
but as a rule of break out games are
simple hot and deep we got our
compelling concept
and so we're we want to figure out the
game around that compelling concept
whatever it is now here's a so a rule of
thumb is the games need to be about a
buck an hour old video games had to be
at least 50 hours we actually shot for
150 hours but 50 hours because they cost
50 bucks and if and if a game was played
in less than that
like the first amount of your solid most
of the people in my studio finish it in
about 8 hours it took me about 15 they
were better game players night and have
my age so of course you're a better game
players now but they played in about 8
hours they all thought it was a terrific
game and to short I thought was a
terrific game period and and quite a
model breaker in terms of games because
it was a full narrative game and and the
narrative was wonderful but so there's a
there's a there's a kind of a quantity
of gaming that we're shooting for as the
minimum and of course we can talk about
the fact that that's that is really the
minimum because we can do a lot better
than that when we have multiple person
games so
I don't know why I'm talking about that
right here ah yes I do
all right so how do you get two simple
hot and deep bullfrog had a very
interesting design philosophy that
almost no game company has done and I
think it is not so uncommon in breakout
game companies they had their concept
they built the game now another kind of
modern idea about about the way we
develop software is that the problem and
the solution co-evolve right this is the
farthest you can get from the old
waterfall model we went from waterfall
to spiral the iterative - well now it's
Koval I won't actually know what product
I'm building until I built it and then
rebuilt it as I'm learning what it does
and how people are using it and I
rebuild it so what what what bullfrog
did 25 years ago was they built the game
and then they started making it fun and
they actually so they had all the game
mechanics in place they had the
overarching goals but then they would
play it and they would figure out how to
make it a great game so they made it a
great game by playing the game and
changing it but you can't do that until
you have the game so they didn't worry
so much about whether the game was fun
as they were building it they spent a
year and a half of a hundred to two
hundred people building something that
they did not know what it was going to
be had any detailed level and then they
turned it into a fun game one of the
reasons bullfrog is no longer here is
that EA could not do that that was just
crazy you have to know in advance but in
fact bullfrog games were great but they
weren't great when they first got built
they were great after they had been
tuned in to being great by playing them
and changing them and playing them and
changing them which actually results in
another interesting fact bullfrog games
were multiplayer all of them every
single one of them was a multiplayer
game
they weren't released as multiplayer
games because there wasn't any way for
people to do multiplayer early on this
was before why you know the on a 9600
baud modem you're not going to play one
of these games multiplayer there's just
no wide area network that would manage
it but within the company they were all
multi player and the way they figured
out how that AI should be written is by
having a human find another human and
then build the AI to do what came out of
that it was very clever and and and
that's part of the reason that their
games were so terrific and seemed so
advanced was that they built the things
that they figured out that you needed to
do by playing it with each other and I
think populace the beginning was the
first game they actually released as a
multiplayer game and and it was it had
to be multiplayer because that's one of
the checkboxes when it came out so it
was checked and at the release party
that we do each time that we were done
with a game and what's going out the
door the two of the best game players in
the company the lead programmer and one
of the lead designers there played and
we put it up on screens like this all
over the company so everybody can watch
and it was bloody amazing it was
incredible we had no idea how good a
game it was until we watched those two
playing it it was an amazing game and
sadly the marketing ramped on a game is
a year to a year and a half long so
while we're figuring out what the game
is there already marketing the game that
they think it was going to be which is
fun but what that meant was you know if
they'd known that a year ago a year
before then they could have marketed
that as being an amazing multiplayer
game but nobody knew that so it was just
like a checkbox yes it's multiplayer and
in fact it wasn't just multiplayer I
mean throwing volcanoes at people and
releasing floods of locusts and and and
vapours from the ground and this and
building a mountain right in the middle
of your village and or a valley or
things like that it's just it was
it was astonishing marketing guys watch
your experts they did but it's too late
because the game is now on the shell
should have fun the kid yes what a thing
they needed yeah they needed to watch
our experts doing that a year before but
we didn't have the game good with it is
a it is annually is it yes well we
didn't we didn't have any expectation
that it was going to be that good we
didn't have an expectation is going to
be that good of single-player game but
we had no idea of how amazing it was you
know it's called a god game so now you
have two gods fighting each other
because you can both do all this yes the
Greeks did all the time
that would have been the hint the Greeks
know how to do this how come how come we
didn't think of it anyway it turned out
to be quite an amazing thing all right
so let's talk about simple so there is
inherently simple such as in simple game
mechanics this is a really simple game
mechanic down up down up it's too tense
for me this is the game I told you it
was too tense for me I don't I like the
game but it's too tense for me I freaked
out at this it's like I play it every so
often but it just it makes me tense when
I play it so but that's not the essence
of simple doesn't necessarily mean that
it has to be that simple in that sense
it simple means that I know what I'm
supposed to do I can learn how to do it
I know what I need to do now things like
that so and by the way this is a place
that collides with a lot of our voltage
UX supposed knowledge consistency is not
necessarily a good idea fitness for
purpose is a good idea what I discovered
in years in the game industry also
testing older people not just the
younglings is that if I met build
something that is inconsistent but
intuitively correct for the purpose that
it serves it is way better than using a
consistent control that is awkward in
that you
this is not a surprise when I say it
that way is it but what but the truth is
that people learn intuitive interfaces
meaning something that fits the purpose
that they're doing very quickly there's
very little resistance to that you don't
need consistency for that it's the
reason that when consistency helps is
when you have an awkward control and you
need to learn a similar awkward activity
using the same awkward control may help
you but because you already know how to
use it but if I build an intuitive
control you learn it faster and you'd be
better at using it another thing that is
important for simple is a great learning
rate so games used to have tutorials
they still do sometimes but when I
started working at EA most games had a
tutorial and the tutorial could be kind
of mildly fun but mostly people didn't
play them that was how you were supposed
to learn the game and the game started
with the assumption that you had played
the tutorial since nobody played the
tutorials and that meant the game
started hard I thought let's not do it
that way let's incorporate the tutorial
in the game so what I did was the first
five levels of populace the beginning
and the first seven levels of Dungeon
Keeper two had a lesson plan that we
thought about wrote up etc and each one
of those levels you learned the lesson
of the level and we made it really fast
boom easy you learned the lesson you
moved on and you didn't die for five
levels and either
there are seven levels and done two
keeper or five levels and you didn't die
my idea here was and I tested this and
it proved to be true even a really
skilled game player that's going to zoom
through all of those really fast as long
as they're moving forward they won't
stop and the ones that aren't good game
players will learn their way through it
they'll move a little slower they'll
learn their way through it and they'll
get to the place they need to be to
actually play consequential levels so
forward momentum became a concept that I
started broadcasting inside the industry
is like there's an idea that the
idea is that early in a game don't slow
people down if you don't slow them down
it's a leveler you can take somebody
from the ground up or you can take a
really great game player to there and as
long as they're moving they'll stay and
then the game better be fun once you get
there but but the point is to get them
there to where they're actually playing
the actual game so that was one of the
one of the things I worked out there
that really worked and and so we so
every game that was designed while I was
there had an instruction plan for the
first levels which was how you learned
the game and that had to be very
carefully thought out with progression
of course you learn one thing and
another thing and another thing and no
death early on nothing to slow you down
early on now the next thing is the
player has to know what their goal is
and that's a grand level of course they
bought the game to defeat the universe
or whatever but it's also at a low level
so so the top one that's that's dungeon
keeper that's that's our good old
dungeon keeper telling you that you have
to do a specific task president ronnie
has been kidnapped by the ninjas are you
bad enough dude your rescue Ronnie
that's a mission right you have your
mission games have to tell you your
mission so you got to know your mission
and that's part of simple I need to know
what I'm doing
I need to know how I'm doing it which
was the ramp and I need to know what I'm
doing which is the mission and that
mission needs to be intrinsically
interesting you won't play a mission
that's not interesting to you so you got
to play something fun
all right cut fun comes from these
compelling action consequence sequences
game mechanics are generally the thing
that makes it fun firing a gun having
things blow up racing a car coming off
cliffs diving flying racing swimming
whatever the thing is that's generally
the fun but sometimes it's not the game
mechanic sometimes it's the game play
resident evils an example of this
Resident Evil has an awkward game
mechanic
it was a great bestseller but it has an
awkward game mechanic because when the
camera shifts the direction you need to
move shifts to hit your target and if if
you're and in many games you move while
you're shooting and if you move while
you're shooting and the camera changes
suddenly you're moving towards the
target you had to change that's an
awkward game mechanic but it didn't
matter because it was great gameplay and
when that camera changed it usually
scared the Dickens out of you because it
did a cutaway shot to something scary
the shots were great they were close-ups
and back shots and the music was was
exactly as it needed to be and so it
worked even though the game mechanics
weren't hot the gameplay was so it still
got to be hot it's got to be hot
somewhere you got to do something hot so
and this forward momentum concept
remains I need to be moving through the
game rapidly so there's all sorts of
games all of them have these loops the
loops are slightly different in
different games you know whether you get
power-ups or a new car or a new life or
you get to buy stuff that gives you more
things all these loops all the time you
got to have them these things give a
person a sense of forward motion and it
makes them feel like they're better at
what they're doing they get the hotter
car they can race faster in the hotter
car actually they race about the same
because that's their skill level but
they think they race faster because we
gave them a hotter car
you got a design depth if you have it in
your game you got to design it when you
lose what happens you get killed by the
enemy what happens this has an
opportunity to really break forward
momentum or maybe you can get some
gameplay and or maybe give them a hint
about what they need to do to do better
next time
so that's hot and then finally deep your
environments get more complex goals or
more difficult or complex as you go
along
obstacles become more challenging and so
on these are the things you would expect
I'm just putting this up here because
this is a pseudo crew game that I play
and each you can choose the level in the
game that you want to play at and each
level requires you to know specific
mathematical things that you use to
actually solve the game and as you see
there's actually 17 levels in the game
but here's like seven here there are
specific solving techniques that define
what level this particular game goes
into and so as you learn these
techniques you can move through these
levels now this is this is cool in a way
but it's also not exactly how I do it in
a game because I want somebody to be
able to play into a new level and learn
it in in the order that is easiest for
them to learn if I'm a combat player or
a fast twitch player I can learn things
one way if I'm a puzzle solver I learn
them another way one of the cool things
you can do in games is is create an
obstacle to be overcome and have
actually two ways to overcome it I could
solve one or the other here in one of
these games you got to know that
technique to solve this game but in a
console video game I can actually make
certain that you can get to the end
without having to know any particular
technique what you don't have to know
this technique you can do it with a
different technique and then what do you
get out of that this part of what makes
games so compelling is is the it's
fierro in Italian the ecstasy of winning
now in order to get to the ecstasy of
winning that's another piece of wow how
games get designed this is the way I
design a game and it's quite explicit I
put these games if the first couple of
hours of play I watch them play it the
first 10 hours of play I watch them
periodically play it the first hundred
hours of playing I guess I have my QA
team there's two hundred people who make
no money out in the backyard playing all
Orbach studio playing all these games
all day long and there's two things I
need to know what level you're playing
at how long did it take you to play it I
want it turned in every night and then
if I see a spike like this unexpected
that's not on my plan then I I put out
to this to the QA studio the next person
who's playing this level call me before
you start and I watch it because I got
to get this it's got to work like this
now this isn't just an esoteric video
game you can see this in in candy crush
crush you can see it there when you win
a really hard one the next one is really
easy and the next one's a little harder
and then it's easier again and then it's
harder again and then it has boss levels
just like a console video game does
those big Peaks those are the boss
levels and when you finally win one of
those you get that now
do I get you to the point where you're
willing to put in that much effort
notice the time scale is also expanding
it takes longer and longer to win
because it's hard so the way I do that
is think of frustration as kind of a
bank account every time you win you put
some money in and you'll use that to win
bigger and then you win bigger and you
put some more money in you put that
money in and you'll be have more money
to win bigger so one of the things I
tell people who would like our level
designers is make friends with the
frustration because your job is to
frustrate people just to the point that
they're almost ready to leave and then
give them a win and give them a big
reward for the win and then do it again
and again and again but each time it
goes higher and that's how you get to
that and once you get that you got them
they're going to keep playing this is a
very this is one of the most powerful
chemical releases pleasurable chemical
releases you can get in your brain
it's a dopamine surge and it's very it's
very engaging you don't want to stop but
you're tired now that's why it has to go
down and I have to and it has to be fast
down like good you're going to knock one
off and knock another one off and knock
another one off knock another one off
you might stop playing for a bit you
come back in knock another couple off
and then BOOM we'll start climbing the
mountain again heading for the hard one
and then that's and in you know in a in
a console game that usually has some
story to it meaning you know the next
bad guy whoever he is that you got to
defeat and you're kind of working your
way towards them
but this is true in this is this kind of
a curve is true and everything you play
it's true in Angry Birds candy crush
it's its crew in in any game that has
had its levels carefully designed to
engage you because we want to move you
to the point where you'll work really
hard to win and then feel really
victorious when you do that yeah are you
literally are you sort of giving a sense
of how the levels change or giving
literally having that number I actually
gave away the prizes I actually these
aren't the actual charts because I
couldn't find any of them but the QA
Department turned in their timing
numbers every day and they got plugged
into an Excel spreadsheet and I charted
them so yeah it looked kind of like this
except there was a bar chart if I
remember correctly yeah why a little too
local tree don't get the difference
lawyers yeah remember that the level the
learning thing I was telling you about
that's kind of what I was illustrating
there I wanted to really guess I you
learn a little bit you get it goes
basically there's only like two two
episodes per level here you know it's
like you play the first one you win you
play this though you play to a and you
win but it's pretty easy and then to be
a little harder then 3a is a little
easier then 3b is a little harder but
you haven't even died yet you're just
going boom boom boom and it doesn't have
to be exactly that way the way you the
way you do the first the learning levels
doesn't matter much as long as you keep
them moving forward and you don't slow
them down but so that's not your right I
did show dips because you can do that
but you don't have to they can go
straight up if you wanted I slowly
straight up if you want it but once you
get past that like level 4 is the first
real level in this diagram but yes I
didn't I don't I think I did bar charts
my memory is I have old bar charts
somewhere lying around of those games
and and when when anything went outside
of a band
you know it wasn't I didn't really do do
stats on this I just looked at him and
when it didn't when it went out of the
band of what I kind of expected now
I didn't define necessarily fully define
all those dips and things some of that
just came out of it because I didn't do
the levels the level designers did them
but I would go to level designer and say
that levels too hard and too early too
hard so you got to pull it back make it
easier and you you get to make yours
harder so so the actual contour is kind
of comes out of the making of it and
isn't fully predicted in advance but the
boss levels are fully predicted and the
fact that we got to get you up to the
skill levels and beat the boss and have
you energized enough to want to beat
this boss with your bank of frustration
and anti frustration in the bank that's
the important part so this is the idea
of that investment you're making an
investment as you go through it and you
see this in massively multiplayer online
games where people sell characters and
accounts they're places where you can go
to buy somebody who's put you know 200
hours into a character and has all this
good stuff and then you just go buy your
way in you won't have the skills but you
can buy the the power yes to do that too
so this is this is that this is the
point that bullfrog made games require a
lot of balance tuning and balance these
are slightly different first you got to
discover the game you build it then you
discover it this is the bullfrog way not
the way any other game company works
that I know of first you got to discover
the game so you build it and then you
discover it
then you gotta tune it so that you can
keep the momentum correct all the way
through it and that includes all the
frustration levels and all that kind of
stuff you've got to make certain that
the losses feel like they are
recoverable that I can learn my way
through this that it is achievable just
like going to Stanford what do you say
and I don't understand yet but I can
learn it if I start feeling like I can't
learn it then I will quit Stanford or
game and then finally there's balance
now most game mini games have all these
things in them and each thing has some
numbers it's a big spreadsheet like how
much power does this have what does it
defeat what can it do blah blah blah how
long I'll durable is it all that my rule
of thumb was we have this spreadsheet we
start with somewhere and we keep track
of it so we have it in essentially a
version control system and if by the
time the game is released every single
one of those numbers hasn't been changed
then we have to then we have to figure
out where it hasn't been changed and go
back and change it well figure out why
it hasn't been changed because in truth
they all need to be changed
that's the tuning of a game and you tune
a game in order to keep people in flow
if it gets too challenging then they
blow up if they if it gets too
challenging they blow up so there's this
whole emotional chart of what kind of
emotion you have depending on where you
are relative to difficulty and skill you
certainly don't want the bottom left
corner apathy but the top left corner is
I'm leaving this is like me and and tiny
wings I just can't do tiny wings it
makes me too anxious so now if you were
designing a game and you had that as
your premise you got to keep them in the
flow you would probably create bumpers
of some sort you'd say oh dynamic
difficulty adjustment I need to have
dynamic difficulty adjustment right
there's a not there's a shake
head back there dynamic discs called the
adjustment we tried it 30 years ago 25
years ago and it's really hard to do as
as such meaning actually trying to make
things easier harder there's all sorts
of unintended consequences didn't really
work but there are natural forms of this
for example in a racing game putting the
gun only in the front of the car if you
get ahead of me I can shoot at you I
knocked you off the track and now you're
behind me but you have a gun in front of
your car so that's dynamic difficulty
adjustment built into the game and one
of the things about this is if I know
how I'm doing if I have good feedback I
know when to back out of a room because
I'm not going to win because there's too
many of them or whatever that allows me
to adjust my movement down the flow
channel which is fun I like that so
there are lots of ways to balance games
oh another one just is I'm sure I got to
fight you and you're too big and
powerful I can't do it but I can solve
all these things over here and get
bigger and bigger weapons now I got
bigger and bigger weapons oh now I can
fight you so that's dynamic difficulty
judgment adjustment and maybe I got
those weapons by solving puzzles which
I'm good at I really don't like fighting
that much but now I got a gun so big it
doesn't really matter boom you're dead
now but I got it by doing these other
things or I'm terrible at puzzles and I
got to break into the safe and I don't
know how to do it so I go and shoot up a
bunch of people and one of them tells me
a clue before he dies and now I know how
to get into the safe dynamic difficulty
adjustment but build into the game
itself that works we did a lot of that
in across our games and that actually
does work but but trying to actually
modify the difficulty of the game every
time we tried that it screwed something
up and just didn't really work
so I don't know where people are in the
state of the art of DDA now but we
couldn't make it work and there were
some principles why which would be a
whole nother talk which I won't give
right now finally I got to get all sorts
of rewards of course constantly
power-ups new cars new guns money houses
friends whatever the game is about I got
to get more of it and you can have lots
of these at the same time they're called
collectables so in Harry Potter you can
get wizard cards you can get Bernie BOTS
beans and those are parallel games but
they actually interact with each other
and with the game itself you get enough
of this and you can do that in the game
so they are essentially power-ups but
there but they through the game they're
played Oh Mario of course stars and then
you end to win when you finish the game
you went a certain way and that way
depends on how you played it so so the
so narrative in games is much better
than it used to be but mostly they are
histories you make the narrative after
you play it how did I win this game and
of course I've got lots of stories about
how I want various games and those are
my history they become my story so the
point here is history becomes story
because we're story creatures we build
stories this is slightly out of order
but part of what you need to do is you
need to know what's going on to get to a
game this is a heads up display which
gives me all sorts of information that I
need to know in this instant so it's
part of the the cycles is what is the
consequence of what I'm doing what is my
current state and finally the last thing
that has really turned gaming kind of if
you want to talk about addictive what
you want to talk about is multiplayer
games because like World of Warcraft
what you can do is
you can build teams where everybody on
the team is different you're the healer
you're the you're the wizard who can
fight certain kinds of things you're the
one who can fight you're the strong man
with a big kind of break open doors you
can do this you can do that and if you
don't get together you can't win
now each of you can play independently
yay and build up your strengths and by
yourself but much of your gameplay is
going to be with your team and my friend
who lost his ear to World of Warcraft
the last three or four months he was
done but he couldn't be because he would
put he'd been let down his team that
he'd been playing with for nine months
and the game has good tools in game for
making appointments for when you're
going to play and what challenge you
want to play and things like that and so
it kept him in a lot longer the other
thing is that I told you earlier about
50 hours 100 hours hundred fifty hours
of gameplay those all require assets but
if you have a multiplayer game I don't
have to keep building things I can just
let you fight other people who will be
creative and interesting and so that
wildly extend the amount of creative
interesting obstacles you have if I set
up the world correctly so that you have
internal conflict so games are
intrinsically an alternative reality
learning experience designed induce a
flow state you're going to learn for
sure at the very least you're going to
learn the physics of the world you're
going to learn the game mechanics you're
going to learn the gameplay you're
probably going to learn tactical and
strategic skills that are needed as well
as hand-eye coordination you're going to
learn you're going to learn don't want
to lose that you're going to learn
specific tools that are part of the game
world and all of that you're going to
learn over a long period of time and
become a man
Saurav in order to complete this game
you're going to master it in order to
get well conditions for flow clear set
of goals compelling purpose personal
agency clear an immediate feedback and a
close match between your perceived
challenges and perceived skills which
then means that you have to know what to
do know how to do it know how well
you're doing it that's what the in-game
display tells you heads-up display know
where to go if there's navigation
involved have high perceived challenges
high perceived skills and freedom from
distractions so that's how it maps to
flow state but what we've gone through
here is a lot of the game design
specific things that you need to do in
order to make all of that work and play
out so that was the rush through ten
years of what I learned in the game
industry obviously I could take any one
of those things apart and talk about it
more but I wanted to give you that
overview because I figured not most of
you would be bored if I talked about DDA
all the time or some other specific
topic yeah it's question time a long
time and if memory serves in an earlier
life you study psychiatry
I call it anti guide rate down so to
what extent did that background give you
the right setup to know what to even be
looking for as opposed to an engineer
that I'm sure would go at this entirely
the wrong direction and not nobody is
trying to accomplish yeah I think that's
a reasonable point so it gives me tools
at multiple levels first psychologist I
I was doing user studies as a
psychologist right now now I call them
play testing or user testing and I don't
do do them with enough numbers to create
the statistics necessary to publish but
the work is the same the frame
the same so like the way I study a game
that I'm developing is pretty much the
way I studied subjects when I was doing
experimental psychology psychology
another piece of it is that a lot of
things that are principles of how people
see and how they behave are things that
come from cognitive psychology I know
this like like I'm looking here and I
have a central peripheral field a mid
peripheral field in a far peripheral
field and I have different receptors
across all of those and what kind of
stimulus will get my attention varies
based on where that is there's some
there was a really great study on the
sakai this year about time with all
everybody who works on things like pop
ups and stuff like that have been having
to solve these problems forever and now
there's finally some studies that you
know eight factors three intensities and
different the three different fields
finally good data didn't surprise me but
nonetheless some of it did luminous
works better than color yeah luminous
works better than color for example that
was a surprise but psychology helps with
the details like that it does and I'm
and I use it a lot anything else that
somebody's dying to know I was in this
study they said you they used it in you
know those things you had your eyes
tested where they're testing your
peripheral vision by blinking things in
denial so they do just noticeable
differences and at different intensities
they're looking for just noticeable
differences at different intensities in
each of the fields and they do color and
luminance as separately they separate
them and see which how they impact each
other and it turns out that color as you
would guess from your knowledge about
where color receptors are in the eye
goes kind of like this moment it goes a
little further out isn't that
interesting so if I want to go a little
further out luminous changes would be
interesting
noticing time do I notice the difference
that's what they're doing when you're
doing your perfect do I see this
difference yeah yeah
games are something where the game
player knows in advance that I'm about
to plow into something that's meant for
entertainment and distraction and
absorption and addiction and all that
Gilbert had a script a couple weeks ago
of suggesting the people designing
actual office application software are
using these techniques in order to make
people get addicted and become
deliberately unproductive so as Sam
hooked on working on something are there
moral issues with these ideas being
applied to non game applications in a
way of of using potential customers I
don't
I think the Percy's example you used I
don't believe but meaning I have never
used an office application I thought was
even vaguely addictive but the but
marketing frustrating for sure but the
reward part is missing oh they're not
good name yes but you know if you look
at our ability to manipulate who to
marketing audiences beliefs and things
which we've seen lots in the last few
years it's getting better better and I
think there are all sorts of moral
political and social implications of
that for sure different talk but
definitely I agree with the implied
concern there that it cool
thank you all
you